don't shoot don't shoot don't shoot the
shooting in the protest have impacted
the first community tremendously through
our daily lives because people are now
kind of in fear for what to do now with
the cops several days without good sleep
running streets to shovel I'm a little
to shovel right now please forgive me
committee as a whole you know the
churches are responding the community
organizations are responding the mosque
is fun everyone in Ferguson that I know
wants peace through justice there's no
race there's no color there's no
prejudice the community is coming
together because what was done is wrong
and we want answered we want justice
you're subject to arrest leave the area
peacefully now the police are hiding
facts they are trying to hide their
message because they know they're
getting caught and then know that this
has been years of just straight
brutality against the Ferguson community
and against our black people I think st.
Louis County and North County has so
many unprofessional poorly trained
poorly paid police departments and
dealing with the public in a rough
handed manner during rush hour with the
public is just their way of doing
business unfortunately it doesn't seem
like you know the Ferguson Police
Department gets that when they show up
to peaceful protests and riot gear it's
almost as if they are expecting the
worst to happen when the people just
want to be heard they want justice they
want
to help alleviate that pain once you see
that how do you expect the people to
appropriately respond when it seems like
you're pushing them up against a wall
everybody's trying to find a way to
balance at all in these last four days
and trying to remain optimistic in
what's to come for justice for Michael
Brown and for his family